hey yeah we're back Oh what is he doing
what the hell pochi looking real tasty
right now god damn it I forgot you were
such a jerk he's being controlled he's
been mind-control well I had this member
[Music]
he's eating me what Wow what what that
ha ha we were friends
that's why they're called man-eaters
what's it supposed to happen I'm so
confused
jeez sighs what is going on here
they hunted them or something it looks
like and then control them for war was I
supposed to die there I think I was
did I just come out of his butthole or
something sorry about that one something
changed what did he react to maybe he
remembered what happened
I will way keep playing the Last
Guardian oh no okay your tonic an ugly
mug ugh
author you to ignore Oh Queen you'll see
I'll get eco
oh the glowing mirror we don't have it
anymore that's why I reacted Oh wake up
okay so we don't have the mirror we
don't know how to wake him up we need to
go here and pull this labor
we gotta yell in his ear or something oh
no something fell on him oh no does this
his wing okay um wake up buddy how do i
wake him up
Oh his tail huh what if I use his tail
to climb on he's always I there we go oh
my god that's so cool yep whoo oh my god
water
I mix like this what where do we go then
this doesn't really help me or does it
Oh what is this
what is this underneath the bridge
that's so cool hey we're first-person
now that's I was enjoying the other
angle this is so okay so now we can dip
in on the other side dip in on the other
side no okay here we go
he's so cute everyone's so cute shock
yacht
I want a plushie I want a tricot plush
oh my god
that is super spooky super spoke see ago
deities II losing in the armor ill on
[Music]
Oh Lu Zhi oh we see uh we got some
enemies I got enemies no shut up
[ __ ] which way this way let's keep our
distance what are you saying
huh not okay wow you're loco crazy
straight-up insane dog all right we're
making it we're making our way out
downtown this music man this way
what are they our other option this way
hey maybe there's some drugs here no
there's nothing there
Who am I kidding why do I keep looking
for drugs I don't know seems like a bad
idea you know it's like a terrible idea
man okay well we got something here it's
already ready okay what is this though
where are we now over here that's
perfect
that works out excellent finally I was
like I know we have to go here I just
don't know how
I hope that wakes him up hey crate them
you still sleep oh yeah
okay all right that's fine no you're
supposed to jump down there that's
exactly how I wanted to do it okay so
don't kill me ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh No okay maybe they're scared of light
ah [ __ ]
don't push me that all these are creepy
as out what the [ __ ] is this oh they're
using get so [ __ ]
I got me let me go on using Nina you too
Drago got him what the [ __ ] huh [ __ ]
Nina juicer and [ __ ] I knew I shouldn't
have done that drink oh wait cow drink
up drink oh yeah oh come on
I need you they're coming Yeti oh oh yes
hey work oh my god it's that ad morning
snack eat him
that's my boy
oh my god
stump in the music
we got more of them I wanna has a sword
and [ __ ]
Oh
oh my god his fighting trick oh damn
damn - trick oh that was awesome oh oh
there's more that's mark [ __ ] okay I
better out oh I'm gonna hear you're
gonna kill me you're gonna kill me Jesus
Christ he smacks the [ __ ] poetry
corner
RTOG you know - oh god he's still crazy
Twitty cool
always okay alright dude I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] such a hype man look at Jesus
Christ okay we better find him some
drugs ASAP
oh we got to pet him that's what I was
thinking but anything hey buddy
that work oh I mean I can't there we go
ah that feels good you know where to
massage my boobs
whoa look at this oh okay
we got a weird footsteps here so this is
where need to go huh Jesus what is this
it see too bad sit back goddamn it shut
up shut up I'm not too fat I mean I I
can't help you with instant weight loss
you know there it is
okay that's cool I'll be right there
trick trick oh my man oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
careful careful careful careful very
careful there you go very nice uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh
No then we jump oh look at that if trick
I saw that he'd be like hell yeah dude
that [ __ ] was hella tight yo oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't want to fall down
out I'd be painting this focus focus
focus focus focus
jump
what the hell that I just do
Hey look that's a hole my favorite thing
in the world how did you know oh this is
a well know it what it's very pretty
take that look at this feel like you can
you can literally just take a screenshot
at any point and it looked like a great
wallpaper you know look at that we're
out but we can't leave our man
he's probably super scared right now
Drake oh this is the cage the stupid
cage Drake oh hey I thought you left
without me is that it's but he backed it
yes I'm packing up you got a problem
where are you I can't see oh there you
want oh I see excellent come on Treecko
all right here I go you're ready for me
nailed it oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ah Aden
nailed it
good job Treecko you will you really did
it there Thanks
oh look at that so much space now never
mind
okay what are we going out
where's it going oh my god I haven't
been outside so long whoa whoa okay we
have some stuff over here well I don't
look at me I don't know where is it
going okay he's going somewhere whether
we like it or not Jesus Christ oh my god
Oh he jumps over cool okay I should get
one of these they seem they seem like
they're handy what now if we go oh my
god you're too fat how many times do I
got to say it
Jesus Christ I just saw his butt okay TC
ish much did you do a site move is that
drugs oh my god
I want to sit that
mysterious aroma
oh is this thing whoa
okay I can I could get up here could I
climb this okay so there's a hole there
you really want that [ __ ] don't you
dude it smells like strawberries okay
all right let's see what we got here
first
Jesus Christ I am a lot braver in this
game than I am in real life all right
okay well we got nothing right I swear I
can fit I swear it okay I'm hoping now
we can grab this branch
oh yes okay finally what I don't that
should have been more obvious to me I am
I apologize I apologize I'm a [ __ ]
idiot let's go down in the pot actually
let's just go down in the ladder if I
can descend okay
there we go that's how you do it
everyone thank you very much I feel very
proud that I did that all by myself
look here we are now oh look at that
there was even this for us who would
have thought got a pushing you got a
shove
BAM ow get back they worked now will you
stop being a [ __ ] prick
ah come man it smelled so nice this is
still seriously trying dude the smell is
gone no no no well now I'm just stuck
honest
oh I'm out I'm out did that on purpose
what happened
now can we continue please oh um what
just happen is he peeing
did he just [ __ ] himself
what was that Sam I cuddled him and he
went to sleep oh my god that's so cute
guess he's tired we have to yell in his
ear to wake up oh it's so cool I made
him fall asleep I didn't mean to do that
I see you I see your smile and all bound
up flow looks like you need a hand too
bad I don't have hands I can make it I
can make it through don't worry about it
okay I'm thinning up I'm a skinny I'm a
skinny
look I made it oh [ __ ] okay
where's his tail I bet his dangling real
oh there I knew it was like perfectly
placed tail oh it smells what did your
say hey don't worry about I'm just
climbing you don't mind this to you
there we go it's perfect
I want this kids outfit that punchy
looks very comfortable yeah your basic
climb in my ass again shut up
oh geez gosh ah there we go
what nice I think we're back gee sad oh
my god okay so where are we now
oh my god what happened I think we got
to jump up on him
he's jumping oh jeez Louise
you crazy oh my god
gee it scares me it scares me on a real
level on a real my god I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die don't kill me don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me don't kill
me okay all right I'm not okay
all right I'm alive somehow I'm just
gonna hold on tie here well what is this
it's a cool-looking place
he doesn't think to mine I'm trying to
jump up Wow so smooth
so pretty
it's incredible mine gosh it's so pretty
Wow you take a little bit hahahaha
I feel so good I haven't had a shower in
like months yeah I knew I knew trust me
oh dude this is the best you should try
boats
I'll be right back okay someone's got to
do the job so is that its Treecko like
The Last Guardian that would make sense
or am I the life we need to go up there
whoa no there's another one I was
literally I thought I heard another one
that's why I was like okay why are they
- maybe we're the last crush someone's
the Last Guardian I am the one the one
don't need a gun to get respect up on
this street sorry okay oh [ __ ]
Wow Christian decided to come in
dode did you that was my cousin Tina
what a great name huh to come up with
that all by yourself
oh okay all right well that's another
way to do it I suppose you can climb on
my tail if you like alright fine I'm
coming okay this is just don't climb
into the bundle oh god don't jump now no
why is this tail so [ __ ] long okay
here we go
dude look at that it looks incredible
that light okay so I need to go there
okay does that still please oh my god oh
my god oh my god
what is happening I'm climbing his eye
there it is
okay nice this looks dark and scary I
like it
Oh Treecko I know we're bros enough
boats don't like me okay all right I
think someone has separation anxiety but
that's okay that's okay we can work
around that there's a bridge here let's
cross it so you can still see man oh oh
oh you just wanted the snack look at him
he just that's it see I don't give a
[ __ ] just want that snack come on give
me that snake please I've been a really
good boy I swear I swear
come on give it to give it to give to
guru what da [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] ass
hahaha oh let's do funny amen
I tried okay I [ __ ] tried you missed
Jesus Christ as hilarious oh my god
now this one is already shattered Oh
even more son [ __ ] I'm so clumsy I'm all
over the place did it
come on buddy you can do it I'm going
what yes I should be a ballerina all
right we can talk about that
we're over now um okay okay I'll use the
stairs cuz I have actual [ __ ] feet
how about that shop whoa look at this
this is cool
should I go down here huh we got drugs
and [ __ ] let's go Wow
probably broke all my legs sir but dude
I got drugs what did that come from
oh my god you were here om gosh no
[ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way what's happening other
enemies there's enemies no no what
don't [ __ ] you jitsu me
what do I do that's right Treecko gadem
you wrecked them Jesus price trick of
running [ __ ]
nice dude that was hell yeah do I got a
comment down again
nice little jumping you got there oh you
got goddamn it
stop attacking Treecko I'm sorry dude
uh-oh there's one more it's gonna hurt
oh hey buddy
hey sir it's show me show how you film
that hurt a lot
hey buddy hey I know you're in pain but
look who got a fate your favorite snack
oh I gotta hit it this time all right
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
take great excellent
oh why thank you excellent I didn't even
know I had to go in thanks Treecko
you're smarter than you look
shut up didn't even want the candy no no
what's wrong with you
[Music]
come back I love you okay where are we
going now Jesus that seems to be
happening a lot it's this water right
hey guys it's fine oh no oh Treecko
I need you [ __ ] [ __ ]
god dammit this is bad
Franco you came i got your mane
we're bros remember all right you you
deal with them huh huh huh huh they
scare me such a [ __ ] okay where are we
now
I don't really know hey come on I think
he's too fat again
where I can't see you I'm too fat sure
you would never say that okay well
clearly this is where we're supposed to
go so cool
the design is amazing oh no we got
Spears what is this one of these doors
they're very mysterious come on
trick oh come on this way buddy there
you go he doesn't want to let me ride
him such an [ __ ] hey what's this and
see this this is this of scenery thing
okay cool great
oh no don't fall don't I bet you're too
fat for that so be careful I told you I
told you it's a trap i drugged Rock oh
no there's Spears ah [ __ ]
we're fine
oh there's something here Oh God
all rights those I'm sure when I pull
this
they're gonna come great [ __ ] hell
Jesus Christ he knew what to do right
away to name get away from me get away
get away get away ma'am well we started
dude there Oh God
[ __ ] sorry wrong turn [ __ ] no not the
Spears
it was a trap help me trick out poke I
hate them
Treecko do something Oh
Pok no that's so annoying Jesus Christ
they're doing something about my tattoos
run I'm running Treecko
what is happening ok I'm going up here I
don't know why I need to help Treecko
I got it I got you come on buddy we're
gross now [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ok alright
if I pull okay I should give you more
space to fight
there you go Treecko yeah Adam
did that do it
hell yeah Treecko you're the man or
woman you could be a what I don't
actually know that's it oh my god what
is happening I am scared
okay okay something happened
great now who's that guy at the end of
this did he kill him did you kill him
dude that was not cool okay he went back
in all right fair enough and here we are
amazing oh I think I see what's about to
come up but we're gonna end that episode
there thank you so much for watching
another episode leave a like if you
enjoy I'll see you in the next one and
as always stay awesome
[Music]